there is something you can do that is
better than anyone else and your job is
to find
it if you can have anything in the world
barring all obstacles what would this be
I love that you started with that
question for me right now it would be I
would like the book to
help I would like this book that I've
written to help that's why I wrote it
and I would like it to help people
uh find their own point of view their
own Artistry what it is they want to do
in the world uh I think we're
lost I think we're we're experiencing
some very very difficult times and I
think time it's very loud it's very loud
right now we're being bombarded even
though we're in our homes because of the
pandemic we are still you know being
bombarded with with media and internet
and social media and what you know we're
lost as to what to do with our
time um education is a little sad right
now you know they've taken Arts out of
school this is a very dangerous thing
this is not just a light thing to take
Arts out of school this is not just oh
we don't have enough money so there's no
art so you do those outside of the
school art is the most important thing
because it teaches
imagination you know art is about
imagination and without imagination we
have no
future you know this is why the artists
have always been the ones to lead us
into you know uh better Waters or the
future or the evolution of mankind or a
higher way or a higher calling it's
always been the artists so if you take
Arts out of school you're not not
supporting artists you're not supporting
the people who are going to teach us you
know how how to live so my thing is okay
well let's find the artist in everyone
then if we're not going to just bring
out the Michelangelo forget the M maybe
this not the time right now we don't
have any Michelangelo we don't have any
Beatles we don't have anything in music
literature I don't see this new wave of
art arriving
so let's bring it out in
everyone um you know I was raised in in
I mean I was in the
70s we had the painting
Evolution it was incredible with Jasper
Johnson Bob renberg and you know we had
gone from from uh one kind of painting
to another and uh I was raised with
these guys at the dining room table and
I would study them and and they you know
they just had their own way of looking
at things the idea was
to see but to see in your own way to see
with your own eyes to find something for
yourself so you know in the book I like
to talk about negative space because we
don't think about looking at negative
space but that's a great example you
know when you look at a tree we're
educated to look at a tree in the same
way there's the branch there are the
leaves there's the
trunk artists look at the tree they look
at the negative space they look at the
space between the leaves they look at
the space between the branches you can
even do an exercise where you paint that
Spa you just do the space and then the
picture
arrives so these are things that
stimulate the imagination this is why
when we have art in school we stimulate
the IM
imagination this is very
important otherwise we follow anything
we buy anything right now we're just you
know oh I think I should look like Kim
Kardashian I need to look like this one
I oh I need to buy these things because
that's very very hip I need to buy the
right sneakers I mean people are
spending $300 on sneakers probably more
I don't know but it's absurd really why
is that one of the central questions in
your life this if you could have
anything okay well my father asked me
that question uh actually I think the
first time he asked it of me I was uh a
a very naughty teenager I was a very
angry teenager I probably get into that
at another time but uh my mother sent me
to live with my father in California
because she said I'm done with her she's
14 and Hell on Wheels and do something
with this kid and so I went to live with
my father and he lived on the beach in
tapanga when there were houses on the
beach in Danga which was I can't even
tell you how fantastic that was and he
wasn't very present when I was a child
because he was an actor and he was in
California working started out on
Broadway but then they took all those
guys to California because it was the
50s and television exploded and so he
came out here to work so I I I didn't
have a sense of him he I had the sort of
formal relationship with him but I came
and I was in trouble and he kind of took
a look at that and he said uh you know
Jossie if you could have anything in the
world barring all obstacles what would
that be and I said I want to I want to
live at the beach here with you and I
don't want to go to boarding school I
don't want to go to private school and I
don't want to do I just want to live at
the beach with you you know maybe this
was a a glib answer but that question
stuck with me and I have been asking
that of myself and of
others uh since that time
um we need to know what we want to do in
the world you know we're not educated to
that we nobody in school don't you think
that this is a smart question hello
you're six what do you like to do what
do you think do you want to do what
would you like to do today you're eight
hi what's going on oh you like the
painting what would you like to do today
you know you have to ask this question
of yourself throughout life what is it
that you want to do you're here on the
planet for a purpose you know there is
something you can do that is better than
anyone else and your job is to find it
and nobody's been helping us do that
so I took that question and presented it
in the book to others this is the most
important question can you answer this
question and you only have answered this
question when you ask it of yourself and
your heart beats you have to keep asking
until something moves in you something
is visceral this is why this word came
out of the teaching
because when you're teaching actors you
have to give them a text technique it's
very important if you don't offer a
really firm technique you're not
teaching you're not offering anything
but beyond technique what what what
makes what takes a a good actor
serviceable actor uh to a great actor to
to an inspirational actor what is that
lift off well it's inspiration it's when
something comes
in that wakes the artist up and that he
can follow and he can
trust and he knows that something
exciting has come in he knows that it's
inspirational because his heart beats a
little faster because he's even nervous
about it because sometimes when that
comes in and you get that kind of a hit
you're anti you I I can't do that that's
too scary you know it's scary now all of
those feelings those visceral feelings
the heartbeat the stomach turn
all of those things are indicators that
you are going in the right path follow
that path so you see what you want you
ask questions until you get that then
you clarify this is the direction I want
to go and this is what I want in life
this is what I meant now you can take
the steps you know then they're revealed
you know if you if you want to be an
actor then you're going to take certain
steps to get to be an actor but it I'm I
want to be an
actor lots of people say I want to be an
actor but unless your heart beats on I
want to be an actor you're just maybe
fantasizing about being an actor you
know your heart has to be you have to
have a purpose for it whether it's
painting whether it's acting whether
it's carving small animals and leaving
them in trees for people to find like
buo Radley you know whatever your bliss
is whatever your you you know because it
moves in you you think people like the
idea of what being an actor is oh yeah
yeah because we you know we have two
parts to us we have the ego the
personality and we have the spirit which
is we are energetic beings in bodies but
we have nothing supporting us in that
way there's nothing to support that
there's no education you know it flows
over into religion well it has nothing
to do with religion religion is
something else you know it's something
you know they've kind of failed us
religions it got a little dogmatic and
people went really so people want to
find that in themselves you know if we
if we looked at all the religious you
know books and all everything and we
were told you nobody can tell you this
you can read these books but they're
just inspiration you know nobody can
tell you what they are that would be
beautiful wouldn't that be beautiful if
you read the Bible if you read the Quran
if you read these beautiful books and
and only you could answer to them this
is what we need only you we need to
listen to ourselves and we don't have
any concept to how to do that so actors
back to the
question you know a lot of actors
personality we're looking at nothing but
actors actors are running all of
advertising you know and everything it's
yeah I want to be an actor I think I
want to be an actor I want people to
look at me like that that's one answer
that comes from you know the ego and I
want to be admired I want to be looked
at and you know that's natural we all
want that and if we didn't get it as
children which is in many many cases
we're going to seek it
elsewhere um but an act there are actors
who it moves in them because their
mission in life is to reveal The Human
Condition that's what acting is it's
revealing the
condition and I liken um actors to
magicians because they're creating life
before your very eyes and when they get
it
right you leave your little life and you
enter their storytelling you know when
an actor enters that realm and they're
living it before your very eyes as if it
were a parallel universe a parallel life
right there and we know that everybody
body knows that they have a thermometer
they go that guy's really in there or
that guy's really acting and the guy
who's acting we enjoy it it's
entertainment but the guy who's elevated
the guy who's living it the guy who has
dared to enter that you know that guy is
working out of inspiration that guy is a
magician and when he's working we leave
we leave our little life and we enter
his life and we take a little vacation
from our own life and and then when he's
done you know we admire that and we
think well if he can control all of that
maybe I can do a little better with my
own
life what does always have something to
look forward to mean I want people to
take the reign of their own life like a
horse and point it in the direction that
they want it to go you know what I mean
if you want to go East you have to go
like this and go east so that was
another thing my father father gave me
he said Jossie always have something to
look forward to and it's very important
because it it helps you to believe that
you are creating your own life you know
I'm going to we talked a little bit
about the artist way and they have an
artist state in that you take yourself
on an artist State and I remember being
involved in the artist way and I loved
it uh but I was terrible at getting the
artist state in because we're you know
the is going to call my attention and
that's going to call my attention and I
have to be at this appointment and and
and we busy ourselves out of the artist
state so to always have something to
look forward to is part of being
responsibility taking responsibility for
your own Joy it's very important that we
take responsibility for our own
vibration if you're a Creator creativity
and joy go hand in hand there is a
school of thinking that is you know the
more pain are tortured and stuff you
know all these artists are you know
great artists are tortured people I I
just don't don't buy it I find it an
Indulgence I believe joy and creativity
go hand in hand so we're responsible for
for creating that in in as in teaching
in my classes my students will tell you
you
know they get morose and they come to CL
and they're like you know so hard and
auditions and you know there no jobs and
now they make you you know film yourself
and you know they just walls of
complaints and some of them have been
around for 20 or 30 years and they're
tired of the industry and they have a
whole another level of
complaints and I asked some things like
you know when is the last time you took
a day in nature you know when is the
last time you did something fun when do
you plan thing you know you know so I
make them make Joy lists I literally
make them this one guy said you have to
go and next class bring me 10 things
that bring you Joy you like doing them
you know and he came back he had one had
one thing on the list Golf and I went
okay golf great next week two more you
know and he kind of pulled himself up
and when you do those things when you
look forward to turned out he liked uh
softball you know so he went into his
softball league and he played in a
couple of games and he came out and he
was like you know that's his Jam man
that made him happy you know uh you know
I'm not I'm far from a polyana
but you're responsible for your own
happiness so when you first you have to
know what you like make a joy list
because you can't put things in the
future if you don't if you're not not
looking forward to them you know if it's
not something you love that's going to
bring you Joy so first you make a joy
list if need be and then you put those
things on the calendar three times a
week why not you know people go one
artist date forget one artist date it's
your life put things on your calendar to
look forward to that you want to do you
want to go to Europe you don't have any
money say yourself I'm going to Europe
in a year and two months in the October
of the la la year I'm going to and where
am I going to go and get specific just
like artists just like actors you have
to get specific I'm going to France
where are you going in France well
research that I'm going to these two
places in France great where are you
going to stay and when you start getting
specific just like you create a part
that's just like creating a part where
are you you know where where you going
to stay all those kinds of questions are
the same kinds of questions that artists
and actors ask you answer all those
questions you put the dat on the
calendar is start a little savings fund
and you know what sorry to seem Airy
fairy but the universe is going to
contribute to that because you are now
operating at a higher vibration and
that's where inspiration comes in sure
and on the flip side not to be too
morose but it can work that way in the
negative as well absolutely absolutely
if when you constantly
worry you will attct things that will
contribute it's really benevolent though
it's really like oh did you want to
worry okay let me help you out with that
you know it it's there's no good bad
indifferent about it it just is you know
uh and if you complain then you'll find
more things to complain about you know
we're so complainy and Meanwhile we're
so blessed with really I have to say to
my husband all the time we're we're
complaining we're complaining about
Ridiculousness here we're complaining
about who's going to cook the salmon
tonight you know what I mean it's like
let we have salmon let's cook it let's
celebrate you I think you said in the
book that uh some of your students they
think there's a career that they want
but really it's someone's career that's
already out there and they're and
they're in a sense emulating that but
they need one that's true for them yes
yeah there was you know I have students
that um and I think it's natural you
know they're very taken with you know
she's a singer she wants to be Madonna
you know he's an actor he wants to be
James Franco or they they see these
people it's a a little bit of a love
affair because there's a lot of
admiration that goes on in the Arts and
certainly in acting and so you know they
they
fantasize what it would be like to be
this person and there's nothing wrong
with fantasy but it's not going to get
you what you want your dream your dream
is not fantasy when you can see yourself
in the picture you
know Madonna for instance that's a very
clear concept of her career she had to
have seen it she saw the costume she saw
the hair she saw the makeup she saw the
voice she saw a presentation Marilyn
Monroe the same thing so that it's just
a tiny shift over to what is that for
you what is that for you if you want to
be that kind of actor which is to create
a whole kind of an image thing there are
different kinds of actors you know
there's Carrie Grant actors and Marilyn
Monroe this is a personality that you
kind of create for yourself that sells
that's a little oldfashioned and then
they're character actors who have a much
broader
uh what is that called Arc of of who
they can play and and some of them can
you know we never recognize them every
time we see them because that's their
goal is they want to enter so far into
character that we don't recognize them
but when they're really good they're
still tethered they're still tethered
they never release once you release it
becomes acty you know you're playing at
something but when you loan your
heartbeat your breath your nervous
system to an entirely different
character who you know then you tweak
the nervous system and it's a little bit
different and you tweak the energy this
one has lots of energy this one is tired
or exhausted or ill but you're still
tethered in on that energy line it's as
if this character's energy were your
line you're feeding it does that make
sense I think so yeah so do you think
most people want to be the persona or or
there's some that definitely want to be
the they want to be the Persona they
want to be admired because we're living
in a really narcissistic Society right
now and narcissists don't admire each
other they don't you know they're not
necessarily kind all of their attention
their thinking is on themselves so we're
in a very thinking Society not a being
Society not energetic being Society but
a thinking society and that's why I talk
about meditation so much because you
know I was just talking to a car a guy
who drove me in a car and I was talking
about you just have that little
separation because he was telling me you
know I get cranky and I don't know my
family and I go you know can you just
look at it just look at it if you can
what meditation gives you even if you do
it five minutes a day it gives you the
understanding that you can step outside
your
thinking which is all sorry ego it's not
we we can't do without ego we have to
have ego it's not a terrible thing it's
just out of balance you know we're just
like all about ego and thinking but if
you can step out a little bit just like
that much you can look and see oh I'm
thinking this or I'm behaving that way
or you know I'd like to change this you
know I had I I get cranky sometimes over
I'm not going to get into why but you
know we're all imp perfect and I was
getting very cranky with my husband we
were working together and sometimes I'm
cranky when we're working together
writing together go no it doesn't go
that way and he is such a beautiful
human being and suddenly I took a little
step out of myself and looked at myself
and went really Jocelyn do do you have
to carry on like this this is kind of
mean and abusive and why are you doing
it and so I looked at my husband just
because I could make that little
separation and said you know I'm really
being a aren't I and he was so
loving and dear and looked at me and
said can can you can you help it can you
just step out of it I go well I've
stepped out this is about as far as I
can go right now you but then we laughed
so what was the question well is it
almost like an outer body experience so
there's the charact there's the Persona
actor which when they walk in um you
know all eyes are on them and then
there's it sounds like there's the
chameleon who can really become almost
another person yeah and and I think the
question was uh do most actors want to
um become the idea like if I just
absolutely adore Kate Blanchett yeah and
and want to become yes everything that
she does and I realize wait a minute I'm
wanting to emulate her I'm not trying to
be the best me the apples and oranges
type of thing it's it it's all from the
same question that's why I wrote the
book there's no connection to self
there's no connection to self so as a
teacher you know I could say to them
you're fantasizing what do you want for
you what is your career do you want
because they also along with that
fantasizing of being K Blanchette or any
one of them you want their career so you
want a movie you want to be a movie star
you know people don't think about
theater as much people don't think about
television they don't think about
creating their own movies make your own
movies you know what is it that you want
to do
because nobody's asked them that so you
have to be asked and you have to
continue to ask until what happens boom
boom boom something Happ only you can
answer that question and only you can
answer that question with your own
nervous system you know with your own
responses so really what we need is
because we need to lead people back to
themselves in their own point of view
and their own autonomy because even with
the chameleon actors often they're
acting out of unhappiness they're trying
to escape themselves and so they can do
this magic trick of really entering but
they're not very happi as people I'm for
like you know let's let's let's have a
little fun in life because we're not
here very long and I want to set an
example I want people to set an example
that this can be fun because right now
it's really
dark and one last thing if I may before
we move on and that is if I and I'm I'm
using let's say the Kate Blanchette
analogy but what if that's not my type
what if I want to be that type but my
type when I walk into a casting office
is someone completely different and so
I'm trying to become an orange when I'm
really an
apple how do I reconcile that with
myself as an actor right first you have
to check on the heartbeat is it do you
really want to be Kate Blanchet do you
really want to play those parts or are
you fantas are you wishing you looked
differently um and if you really want to
play those parts you can find a way you
know there was a a model I grew up you
know I was a really bad model but that's
another story um but I worked with some
around some very good models and you
know Twiggy was a big deal the eyelashes
and stuff we looked sort of alike but
there was a a woman named Penelope tree
who was a model and she didn't really
have the face of a model and but she
wanted it she had a heartbeat for it it
was a real thing for her so she
created a face with Kabuki she made a
white face with very extreme makeup and
she wore very uh geodesic kind of not
geodesic geometric clothes and she had
poses that no one had ever seen like you
know she was very I just odd
strange uh poses she created her own
thing she was a huge hit why because it
came from her imagin like madama you
know it came out of her imagination she
saw it you have to be able to see
yourself in it um if it's not from your
own heart you're never going to get
there here's another example I'm not
going to mention her name but you know I
trained with a beautiful actress I love
this woman who wanted to be KL she
wanted to be a movie star and she was
never going to be a movie star she was
you know from kind of coal mining she
was Sal of the earth babe that sort of
is recognizable to all of us and my
teacher uh who was Milton
celis he was he was very hard on people
I don't believe in being that hard
either but he was very hard on her and
he kept telling her you know you're not
going to play these parts you're not
going to stop doing scenes from these
parts because you're not going going to
play these parts you're salt of the
earth and finally he
said he he hit home with her it maybe it
was the sixth critique maybe the 10th
critique and he looked at her and he
said is Anam manani not good enough for
you and she didn't know who Anam manani
was and so she went and she looked up
Anam manani and she realized what he was
talking about and she realized the
wealth of parts available to her as a c
character actress and she I'm getting
Goosebumps she started working and she
hasn't stopped since she's in everything
she's in everything so it is finding but
it had to ring in her heart she had to
look at Anam manani and go oh I feel it
I see myself in it you have to see
yourself in
it why is thinking bad I don't think
thinking is bad I just think it's
overdone you know we just we think all
the time all the time all the time you
know I had trouble sleeping last night
because of something that's coming up
that you know is a bit of a problem for
me and I'm going to have to figure out
how to handle it in a you know good
way so I started thinking I I'm thinking
and I'm thinking and I'm thinking and
I'm thinking and I'm going oh my God I'm
driveing myself crazy with thinking that
I'm going nowhere with this thinking
it's just worrying so to my much
thinking worry how much do we worry all
of that worry is useless
thinking how much do we think about the
past all this did I say that was that
okay I don't know what happened
yesterday with that woman I don't know
you know we think about the past we
think about the future those they don't
exist there is no past it happened it's
done there is no future it hasn't
happened yet it's going to be born out
of your actions right now so we're going
to think it's a beautiful tool we're
Spiritual Beings in
bodies and we're here to have an
experience and we have these Fantastic
Tools like thinking which is overused
and tasting and smelling and hearing and
feeling and touching and hands that can
play instruments you know it's all
pretty much a miracle if you allow
yourself to look at that way uh but
thinking is taken over and thinking
thinking is taken over because there's
so much noise you know we want to I want
to think about these reals I just get a
little shot of Serotonin or dopamine or
whatever these reals are giving me and
think about what it'd be like if I had
800,000 people following me I don't know
what they're thinking about but it's you
know it's overused too much thinking
it's not a bad thing but it's it's way
over us probably we should probably be
thinking
25% of what we're saying thinking the
rest of the time we should be being in a
space in the
moment finding yourself in the moment
and that's another thing as you find
yourself in the moment and you're able
through meditation to kind of create
space and just be we're human beings
who've forgotten how to be but when we
can create create space and just be
that's where inspiration comes in that's
where things come out of the sky and not
out of the sky out of The Ether out of
the ethos and I believe this is a
communication from outside ourselves to
lead
artists you know we get hits and we get
Inspirations to lead artists to lead
Humanity because artists lead
Humanity so that doesn't happen when
you're thinking the ego is think the ego
loves to think I think about this I
think he likes me I think she's nasty I
think I'm G to you know I'm think I'm
thinking thinking it's it's uh it's too
much actually the ego is thinking
because they're terrified that we are
going to show up in our power and take
over which I believe is what's happening
I believe Consciousness is rising very
very quickly and the reason that the
planet feels so Rocky is because the
darkness is right just as quickly it's
all happening very quickly you know kind
of like a race and all we can
do is be ourselves be ourselves and
raise our vibrational level with joy
with gratitude there are definite ways
that you can make yourself feel better
and in that this is what I think artists
I think you know artists think they're
their talent
they think by the way they think they're
their talent and they get very unhappy
with me because I you're not your talent
they don't like that much I say your
talent or your the reason of your talent
is your
sensitivity artists vibrate at a high
they're very sensitive and they vibrate
at a very high frequency and it is in
that frequency that they receive you
know Michelangelo
what's in the marble let's see I'll take
that away and that away and that away
and I don't know if you've ever seen the
David but it it t just thinking about it
it takes your breath away that a human
being created that that comes from the
ethos that's your higher
Consciousness talking to you I think you
talked about in the book that with the
higher frequency it can have a flip side
as well so we've seen let's say van go
or something where the artist can go to
a dark side which can be very detrial
yeah and that's something that we have
to watch as sensitive people yeah yeah
and how does he get to the dark
side thinking what do you think what's
on Van Go's
mind there's a lot of thinking going on
I'm I'm not good enough I'm to I'm not I
can't I don't fit in I don't you know if
you just give people the grace
of just being of just
steing
themselves you know
Stillness extraordinary just the balance
if I just do that for one second like
that you see the balance of the I don't
know maybe he likes me maybe he doesn't
like me maybe I should call maybe I
shouldn't call maybe maybe there's
something on my email maybe there's not
did they email me I don't
know you know just practice being
practice Stillness practice breathing
into your heart but I never say his name
right but I'm going to say it anyway
tick n tick Nan is that right tick N I
think so anyway that magnificent
Buddhist who brought you know meditation
or mindfulness to the to the West you
know he
says I breathe in I know that I am
breathing in I breathe out I know know
that I am breathing out that's
it this is such a gift to self five
minutes and it's a gift to self because
it's a gift to you as a spiritual being
not thinking and not your future or not
your past or not any just be here
now 5 minutes a day and you won't by the
way your thinking will come in and then
go I think that you know that's okay you
it's not bad you just go oh thinking
just note it go back to breathing that's
the practice it's like flexing a muscle
there is no wrong way to meditate you
know I didn't I didn't want to meditate
I have a busy mind and I thought I'll be
terrible at it and I don't like to do
things I'm terrible at I'm you know I'm
sure meditation is great but I'm you
know I'm not going to be good at that
but then I had to I felt I had to I had
a high blood pressure thing you know
they said oh your blood pressure s you
got to take medications you know and I'm
like no I'm not taking your medications
I'm I'm very no medications thank you um
so I thought I'll do it with diet and
and try diet and meditation and I did
went down to normal so I took a class
you know in in mindfulness it was
wonderful and I realized oh that's how
you Flex the muscle you you're breathing
I breathe in I know that I'm breathing
breathing out and I breathe out I know
that I'm breathing out and then I'm
thinking oh okay I'm thinking just note
it and go back to breathing just note it
that's how you teach yourself to create
space that's a thinking space this is a
being space two very different things
thinking space Oh I'm thinking you don't
even have to judge it oh okay I'm
thinking I think I'll have a Heyday with
this thinking I'm going to go right on
you know with this thinking I like it or
oh
being thank
God I needed a break from all that
thinking I'm hoping we can talk about
Soul speak uh I think in your book you
talk about mental chatter and when we
have mental chatter we enter a space
where we can't hear Soul speak yeah what
is that well this is what I was just
really talking about
um you know there are different
languages on the planet we're we're just
like we're obsessed with thinking we're
obsessed with English we're obsessed
with language you know and English you
know Americans don't even learn other
languages because we get this good
language can't be bothered they all need
to learn to speak English anyway or
whatever it is but you know we we're
obsessed with language language is a
wonderful tool but like thinking it it's
it's way
over you know you you know it's too too
much too much talk talking
so you know I talk about these things I
hope that they're interesting to you but
you know there's you can have
communication with trees and you can
have communication with rocks and you
can have communication with the ocean
and you can have communication with sky
and you can have communication with
animals people understand that you know
they have deep really loving wonderful
Communications with their animals you
can do the same thing with any life form
on the planet planet and you know that
that
alone if you have to listen for your
energy exchange with the
tree you know then you're able to listen
to the counil of your own
heart um which is really your higher
Consciousness which is really all
Consciousness you know we're all the
same we're all expressions of the
universe it's very clever the universe
I'm going to all these people and it's
they're all going to have different
reflections of me I'm going to give them
all the same tools and go and then you
know the person you know would lives in
a matrix you know they they think and
they create their life you're doing it
so if you're doing it going east you can
just as well turn the corner and go west
with your own thinking and your own
actions and your own
desires
um so the question was Soul speak how do
you listen to your soul you know that
happens in Stillness but it also happens
by accepting the fact that it's a
different language it's you know
thinking is in English you don't think
you know in anything but English you all
your thoughts are like you know they're
language
thoughts um listening to your soul is
not a language it's an energy exchange
like with
trees you know when when I was little
you know I was I was really
lonely um so did did I talk about the
fact that you know I had parents and
they were artists but they kind of just
put you on the planet and said go and
there wasn't really a lot of um you know
hugging or cherishing cherishing is such
a beautiful word that we should cherish
each other like a husband and wife
cherish each other what does that mean
that means that you're going to practice
kindness that means you're going to
practice the Gratitude of having that
person in your life that's what
cherishing is so I don't I don't
remember that being a child and I I
really thought it should be there you
know I had a lot of ideas of what a
parent should be and you know people
should listen to me and acknowledge me
and you know I had these ideas and I
wasn't getting I I wasn't doing well
with people I wasn't doing well with
people I didn't find them authentic but
I lived in the woods we lived we had
Woods surrounding us so I would just go
to the woods all day
and you know it's like being in a Disney
movie I mean sometimes I think you know
you sound like Disney jawsome but I
don't care it's true you know I had
relationships with trees and this one
was you know female and this one was
male and this one I talked to about
certain things and this one not and that
one I didn't really have a relationship
with and that one I something went wrong
with that one I don't want to go over
there it scared me you know I was
working with the energy fields and very
communicative and I felt felt they
raised me I had certain trees that I
really took counsel from now what does
that mean I mean did they speak to me no
but they it's like having a chiropractic
adjustment they would I
would maybe ask questions of the tree or
I would look to the tree with my energy
field of I am unhappy and lost and the
tree would send back something to my
heart that was so soothing it's okay
we're here
here and so that was kind of my natural
state with things and then one day I
realized I could communicate a little
more because you know I was going to
school and it was my birthday was coming
up and I felt very un birthday ask I
think this was going to be kind of a
celebration of my dreams which would
just be for somebody to see me and go Hi
how are you what are you doing here what
do you want to do you know you know um I
see you I see that you're special I see
you've come for a reason so I was
feeling very sorry for myself and I was
I just don't get it I don't get why they
don't see me I mean I I came here I
thought you know I would make my parents
happy I should see that joy in their
eyes you know where's the joy in the
eyes you know they just look kind of
worried to me I I don't get it and I
heard this was not
language but the closest thing a concept
concept and this artist work with
Concept all the time the thing comes in
not as language it comes in as concept
and how do you know it's concept because
it hits your heart something moves in
you and you go what and it came in you
know we're here and we might just have
to be
enough and I
went you know okay that's good I it
would be nice to have a third
dimensional person somewhere down the
line you know but I heard it loud and
clear and from that time on I could kind
of get around and feel like okay this is
my place my place is these kinds of
communications and then later in life it
was to pass those gifts on or those
Concepts to others who might enjoy them
you know I knew there were going to be
lots of them
going that's fine that's fine you you
can't be responsible for people's
response you can only be responsible for
your intention and what you offer as a
human
being what's the difference between
thinking and knowing well we think we
know a lot and we think we know out of
judgment you know we're very judgmental
society and and and we're kind of
desperate in the in the in the you know
thinking we know we got to know we got
to know I mean really I got to know so
I'm going to look at this thing in order
to know and I'm going to
know when I judge it because when you
judge it you go oh I know it's la la la
I know it's this I know it's that so
that is a kind of a desperate need to
think you know and it serves the ego
well because the ego feels smart and it
protects us because oh I know I don't
have to go near there because I know
what that is so thinking that you know
come out of judgment and of which
there's a lot when you know that you
know you know it because you know what
you feel it it's visceral this is why we
have this uh degree of sensitivity and
um you know people say oh you're
Clairvoyant no not Clairvoyant just a
higher tuning on that
intuitive intuitive senses you know
people talk about um emotional uh
intelligence the first time I heard that
every once in a while I go to a
therapist and then I go I don't
know what I'm doing here but um I had a
therapist once say oh you have a you you
you have a really strong emotional
intelligence and I said what is that and
she described it as you know a very high
intuition toward this is truth or this
is serving me it's a very high intuition
which makes sense because you have to
have that you know when you're growing
up and you're unsure so you start
observing things like crazy to figure
out what is going on now you're not
observing these things to judge them
you're observing these things for
survival so you're open to what is it
you're really looking at it and feeling
it up
right so that's a highly
attuned intuition that's knowing when
you
know everybody's felt it you know I just
knew I met him and I knew I met the guy
I was going to marry or I knew this was
the house for me when I walked in the
door or I knew you know people talk
about it in that way that's all that is
it's a hit with intuition and then a
trust and then a moving forward with it
um but there's a lot of thinking you
know you know thinking I know I know oh
yeah I know I got it sort of a glib
judgmental you know thing and judgment
is something that it's another one of
those things you want to separate out a
little bit and go God I'm being really
judgmental aren't I I'm just being
really judgmental of this person um
during the pandemic a couple of things
have happened you know CU we don't see
anybody I mean we've been pretty
isolated my husband and I for a long
time we do see people but now that I'm
promoting the book and we promote the
film I'm meeting all kinds of people so
sometimes you know I say but you know
somebody will say oh we want you on your
P podcast and I'll kind of look into
them and see them and sometimes I'll go
oh they're from so this place and I
don't know anything about that place and
they're not going to know anything about
me and my first thing is protection to
protect myself cuz it's a little nervous
making putting yourself out there
particularly having not done it for
three years so the first thing might be
judgmental I start looking for ways not
to do that thing and then I go and I do
it and I talk to this person I talk to a
guy in Virginia in coal mining you know
and I thought you know the first thing
was like this is I love this man i' love
so when we open ourselves to the human
being the other human being it's it's
really quite a spectacular thing and
that's a
reach to know each other on a human
level as opposed to oh I know what that
is that's a guy from coal mining company
in Kansas who's you know wants to be a
radio host and whatever it is you know
uh then guy turned out to be a high
school teacher which
is you know I have they're like
firefighters to me High School teachers
right now I think they're the great
Heroes of the world and you know after
the we did an interview together we
spoke as two human beings about the
state of education and his dedication to
teaching and you know you can't get
there if you judge somebody before you
even meet them so it's all about moving
forward with an open heart
really we all need to to to find that
Stillness in ourselves and open our
heart and walk forward with an open
heart because what are you going to
protect yourself from you know Co okay
wear a mask you know I mean we don't
need to protect ourselves we need to
live we need to find ourselves we need
to listen to ourselves we need to find a
way out through
guidance sure well I mean it's
understandable but you don't know
someone's agenda when you come into an
interview or you could say the same for
an audition someone could say you know I
love this person's work and and I know
I'm perfect for it and then they go and
they're met with just a stone wall and
and they're crushed because they thought
they were going to see me and they were
going to go you you're the one yes and
it turns out they barely they didn't
even get your name what's your name
again okay well and this is that's so
beautifully said and not only that that
was a terrible experience for actors to
have to constantly go in for auditions
and it's as if the people auditioning
them were trained to be like the parents
I told you about like nothing NADA not
see you for an artist not to be seen
even when they're working from their
heart no matter where they're working
from whether it's a concept in their
head or a concept in their heart for
them not to be ex SE seen is just it's
criminal really because they're the ones
that are going to lift us up out of this
stuff we should be going thank you for
coming in but so how do you handle that
you emulate what you
want if you didn't like the way your
mother did it then do it that way for
your daughter and you'll heal yourself
and you'll pass on and evolve the next
Evolution to it if you don't like the
way the people are behaving toward you
change your attitude don't walk out
feeling justified in ain't it awful
they're really shitty to me they didn't
even see once again I'm right I think
I'm right once again the last 10 they're
all terrible you know it's really hard
if that person is stone-faced if you
don't take it personally because it
certainly has nothing to do with you if
you don't take it personally you just
look at them think maybe they had a bad
day and you look at them and lock eyes
and go Hi how are you they're going to
respond if you offer them your heart
they're going to respond and my counsel
to my actress is that's your
job Change the World by
example go in and be you know they say
Be the Change you want to see that's a
real thing it's a little harder to do
than to say but it's a wonderful
practice we are what we practice period
you know if we don't practice anything
then the world's going to be happening
to us and we're going to be like you
know at effect to whatever comes into
our lives you know if we practice
certain things we practice many
meditation so we can get a handle on
when we're behaving in ways we don't
like we can look at it and go yeah I'm
behaving in a way I really don't like
you know when we practice gratitude we
can raise our we can raise our our our
vibration it will when we practice doing
the things that bring us joy we raise
our vibration we begin to to to take our
life in the directions that we want to
take it it's it's really
simple it it's really simple it's just a
little difficult believing in Simplicity
to that degree
because you say in the book that the the
first piece of art that an artist
creates is their perfect life or the
life that's best suited for
them hopefully but unfortunately you
know but that's the way I'd like people
to look at it you know people go well
I'm not an artist they go you are an
artist your life is your first
Masterpiece you know you're either
creating that or you're creating it
whether you are consciously creating it
and moving it in the directions that you
want to or whether you're creating it
with your own thoughts whether they're
negative or in the middle you know
you're just thinking all the time
thinking thinking looking at screens you
know just bubbling
along it's a reflection of everything
you do and everything you say and
everything you think combines together
to make your future that's going to be
your next moment this moment is going to
unfold into that moment and that
moment's going to unfold to the next so
if this moment you have brought yourself
Joy on purpose you've lifted your own
frequency out of your own
practices then that will flow into a
different kind of moment than if you
hadn't done that consciously does that
make sense so you you give people um or
you ask sorry not give but you you ask
your students to do different things to
raise their vibrations whether it's just
taking a walk in nature or petting an
animal well when they get
morose you know usually I'm teaching
just acting I mean I teach a lot of
things but but actors get morose people
get morose and they get
complaining and you know I'm like what
are you complaining about do you have a
roof over your head yeah do you have
friends yeah you know do you have car
yeah you can eat yeah you know what are
you complaining about yeah but they're
they're righteously terrible things
going on in the world but you'll do
better with those things when you gain a
little control over your own emotional
state you can call it vibration you can
just call it emotional state but that's
in your charge that's your
responsibility and if you're walking
around like a sad te I call it it would
say eore you know so you know the
student would be in a critique and they
would go yeah you know a thing and the
thing and I'd go oh it's like Eeyore you
know you know Eeyore and poo just walked
around just sort of morose and sad all
the
time well you
know the movie where they go get out of
snap out of it you want to smack them go
smack snap out of it instead I give them
exercises you know sometimes they get
into it collectively like right now we
are collectively in a kind of a morose
agreement
about the pandemic meanwhile the
pandemic has made some important
adjustments by the way in life but we
don't look at those we just go we're Mor
we're like oh boy the pandemic you know
ain't it awful but it's brought about
some group things but I would come to
class sometimes and I would feel they
were in a a collective unhappiness the
whole room you can feel it you know
sometimes I come into class and
everybody's like let's go we got work to
do that's what I I like to create out of
and if the room isn't like that I'm
going to address it that's a little
different than some acting classes you
know but it's like we're going to work
from up here we're not going to work
from down here and if you're working
from down here sometimes I just make
them stand up and jump and that whole
room is jumping up no no no no no and
they're doing it like this I go no it
has to be at the same time so now they
have to listen to each other and then
they finally get at the same time by the
time they get at the same time they're
laughing and their energy is up other
times I think it's you know there was a
a certain election that happened and
there was a certain
Collective morosity I don't know
moroseness in the room and I go what's
going on they're like so I I said when
when is the last time you when is the
last time you went out into nature
when's the last time you took a day I
take days in nature because I can't live
without it when's the last time you know
nothing nothing came the room was dead
and they went
seriously when is the last time you went
to you know the gardens or the ocean or
the mountains or took a walk in nature
when is the last nothing so I assigned
them to go out to it could be the
mountains could be could be a park but
you had to go alone you had to turn off
your electronics and you had to just be
you had to just sit there and observe
things around the grass the tiny things
the large trees the o
the sand the little crabby bugs in the
sand just If You observe you know you
stop thinking when you observe so a lot
of my teaching has to do with
observation so I should just go out and
and observe and turn off the phone and
do it for an hour and uh they came back
to CL and I said oh and I said and then
when you come home I want you to find a
rock or let the rock find you and bring
it to class you know and before you you
pick it up I would say this is just me
before you pick it up I would ask it
permission because that rock has lived
there for quite some time and you are
moving it from its natural environment
so I would ask permission and if you
feel it's okay you know take this rock
that you spotted in a special way and
you know as a as a thank you for this
experience that you had and bring it to
class so I came to class and there were
these 50 rocks lined up on the a
of the class they were beautiful and the
room was just crackling with energy and
they wanted to talk about they wanted to
talk mostly about how disconnected they
were from nature how powerful it was you
know one young girl maybe the youngest
in class had never spent time in nature
that's what these telephones and social
media is doing to us had never thought
it never crossed her mind I think I'll
go to the beach by myself and take in
the power of the ocean I think I'll take
a walk in the woods and commune with
trees you know in Europe they have a
whole Forest bathing because they
understand the power of of walking in
forests and they were crackling it was
fantastic anyway the young one got
scared she she said she was really it
was so big the energy was so big and so
different to her that it scared her and
I said well were you scared like a bear
was coming scared or were you excited in
a new kind of a
way and she said I was excited and the
minute was over I was she said I only
did 20 minutes because it was so big she
said but the minute was over I wanted to
do it again like a roller coaster so you
know simple simple simple
things are
very powerful truth is very simple lies
are very complicated the more
complicated something is the more lies
it has in
it can you explain how someone quieting
their mind can lead them to their life's
purpose
okay quieting your mind or steing
yourself by breathing into your
heart is taking you to a place of being
as I've talked about it's taking to a
still space where you can just
be in that space you can ask yourself
questions this is the same space that
artists go to ask questions for
inspiration so with an actor you always
you're always acting in a place that's
number one the environment where where
am I most of the time actors are not
moved by their environment at all you
know that that doesn't doesn't matter to
them they're they're busy acting they're
busy saying the
words um but you know you are in an
environment and I train actors to touch
the chair to feel things and first of
all to make choices about where am I
where am I what makes it so so if you're
you know in class I'm in a bedroom well
what makes it so well I'm going to bring
these things it's my bedroom so I'm
going to bring my bedding I'm going to
bring just enough enough of my own
things my props and my personal
possessions to help me believe in this
space if you're an actor and you're on a
set and you can't bring those things you
go around the bedroom that's your
bedroom and you talk this is my bed
which side do I sleep in what's in the
drawer you know I'm a pain in the ass on
said I'm all over the place this is my
thing I got to claim it I have to
believe in it so the first thing is that
space so so I ask you know you might ask
the question well where am I in this
scene and then it's obvious you know
you're in your bedroom yeah but where
could I
be well you could be in the kitchen well
where else could I be I could be in the
garden what if I was in the garden now
something lit up with you in the garden
well how would the garden work so it's
all series of questions and then how do
I create a garden well I'm just going to
put three or four plants I'm going to
put this chair and then that's going to
be my garden what makes my garden well
what are you doing in the garden what
are you doing in the garden because it
doesn't come alivee for an actor unless
he's doing something unless he brings it
into Behavior because the story is told
in
Behavior so I went on that little detour
to say that's where you ask questions
from is that space so when you still
yourself and you breathe into your heart
and you ask yourself you know what do I
want to do in life why am I here what is
my purpose in that
Stillness something can come in whether
it's
inspiration to answer a question you're
posing as an artist or whether it's
inspiration your higher self to help you
along the way to knowing what it is you
want to do and what your purpose in life
is I think you had used an example in
the book of a a gentleman who had turned
50 yeah and he was a police officer and
he realized this was his what he felt
was his one chance to become an actor so
you had him create his space in the
locker room getting ready environment
that you know this uh environment
exercise which I I've been writing about
for years and years and years but it is
the most powerful thing because with
actors you don't give them words at
first they only have two things they
create an environment and then they do
the things they really do in that
environment so first they have to
observe their life so this is the the
training always begins with observing so
they observe their life for their life's
rhythms so this guy came to me and you
know I interview every
student mostly for attitude it's all
about attitude because you know I'm I'm
old and I don't want anybody with my
crappy attitude that I had when I was
you know an actor so I want people with
happy attitudes and to create a you know
very uh a group that reflects all of
humanity all ages all colors all sexes
you know I like an even even amount of
men and women and such so this guy came
to me and I was interviewing him and he
said uh he said he wanted to be an actor
and you know he he always wanted to be
an apple actor but he thought it was a
pipe dream and so he kept putting it
away do the right thing became a cop but
now he was 15 he thought I'm never going
to get to do it I I want to do it and I
don't know how he found me but that's
the universe always kind of puts those
connections together so he found me and
I went oh okay so I wanted to check on
his uh commitment so I said uh are you a
good cop and he said yeah I'm a great
cop I go oh yeah what makes you a great
cop goes because I care I really care I
go
excellent can you give that same
commitment to acting in my
class you said yeah I said okay you you
can come to class now this guy is a
beginner beginner and he's coming to
class with people who are currently
shooting series I put them all in the
same class it's all attitude and he did
his first exercise and the first
exercise the environment exercise you
create a place right so first he
observed he observed himself in his
locker room to the police
station and he observed every detail of
his behavior and he noted that and he
rehearsed that without the locker room
so he could figure out how he was going
to create a locker room on stage in the
theater and and then he created this
locker room and he did those behaviors
ex with the same investment it's
different though because now he's
consciously doing them he said he did
things inevitably actors discover this
in observing his own behavior he
discovered that he did things he never
knew that he did he just did them
automatically now he's doing them
consciously and he's really investing in
the behavior he's really doing it
consciously exactly as he does it
in life that brings an actor to the now
that brings him to the present moment
just doing and believing in that
space without words without emotions
without any story just being and doing
that's like this those are the first two
steps this guy did this exercise and he
was he was about to leave the exercise
he was almost finished and he had a
thought went to his locker room we saw
when he it was just a box but he opened
up the box and had a picture of a guy on
the thing which was a buddy who had died
in service and he had a second thought
and he put He undid his jacket and he
put on a bullet proof Fest and he put
his jacket back on and he looked at the
guy very simple and he left the scene
that was the end of the exercise I could
have put a camera on this this is the
guy's first time ever on a stage and
life he didn't even do little plays as a
child this is his first time ever and uh
he was beautiful he was just a person
when you are really behaving as a person
and doing things exactly as you would
and responding to an environment exactly
as you would in life this is acting so
simple it's very difficult to allow
yourself to be that
simple we learned by example we we
change by decision we move forward with
intention yeah I mean that pretty much
covers it you know sometimes I I read
things from my own book and I don't
remember them at all because a lot of it
is it just comes in it just was very
very fluid experience but you know we
certainly learn by example you know
we're set up that way as beings you know
uh we grow up we learn to walk we see
our parents walk and we see them eating
a certain way we you know we learn
everything by those around us as an
example for quite a long
time the thing is the next one is
trickier we change by decision right
that's a little trickier because you
have to be conscious to make a decision
but we have moments where life sometimes
pushes you know there there's something
happens in life and we go oh we make
this decision we we get this impulses
very strong impulse that we have to uh
make a decision and those are and we can
all find those periods of time in our
life that where we made really important
decisions um my husband is a filmmaker
he was a director and he was a teacher
at USC and this is one of the first
things he would ask his class to you
know identify a decision that they made
in their life that was life-changing
that moved them in a New Direction so we
all and and they love it and they come
up with these things and then he shows
them how this is a great uh seed for a
film is because these
are in you know they're impul they
happen from your heart I need to make a
decision here they're big they're
conscious we move forward the intention
is the practice you
know we are all really worried spend a
lot waste a lot of time on worrying what
other people think of us I I did anyway
and if you're an actor actress are like
you know it's do they like me do they
not like me what do I have to do to get
this job how do I have to act to get
this job you know that's the problem
that they kind of hear the part in their
head and then they go into the audition
they deliver this part that they hear in
their head that came from the words on
the page and having been on both sides
of that experience I can tell you that
90% of the actors who come in they don't
even come in anymore they have to film
it but 90% of the actors who came in for
an
audition would give the same audition it
all sounded the same way it came off the
page and hit their ear in the same way
so
um intention is everything um when you
move forward intention an actor moves
forward like I don't I hear that I hear
the call of the while I hear the words I
hear how it seems like it wants to be
played
but I'm going to intentionally ask some
questions here what could this be what
could be going on what could he be
thinking what could he be responding to
what could he want what could is the
question and then you repeat those
questions that's the intentionality in
art in acting that's the intentionality
what could it be I want to discover
something that Rings true in my own
heart so that I can make a
Discovery because without Discovery it's
not yours but I made this discovery now
I want to play this now I have something
to offer that comes from me and nobody
else doesn't come from my thinking of
what I heard when I read the words it
comes from a discovery I ask some
questions I discovered this thing oh I
can give it that I can give myself to
that so
intentionality I intend to live a life
where I'm connected to myself I intend
to live a life with a certain amount of
Stillness in it so I can listen to the
environment and to what's outside of
myself I intend to be kind so I'm going
to practice that I intend to help others
so I'm going to make a list of things
that I can contribute to I intend to
contribute I tell actors and uh others
in the book we're not taking that to
other people who want to live a more
intentional life you
know what what are your intentions you
have to look at your intentions when you
make a decision ask yourself how does
this contribute if your intention is to
contribute as a human being to help lift
the planet up a little bit then with
your decisions you ask yourself how does
this contribute does this contribute
does this thing that I'm doing
contribute to my health to my family to
my community Comm To The World At Large
does a contribute that's a great great
intention is
to walk forward with asking yourself you
know I want to contribute how do I
contribute how do I make the right
decisions how do I become the best
person I can be it's that simple imagine
if we were taught as little children
your job is to become the best person
you can be not your job is to learn what
date the you know war of two Savages
happened I can't even think of the wars
you know what I mean I that doesn't
stick doesn't stick who needs that
nobody needs that what we need are
people there's there's something magic
about
atomy autonomy is being able to move
forward with self and that happens
because you have gotten to a place in
your life where you say I trust my
intentions I I've been intentional
enough enough to know that I trust my
intentions so I can't really spend I'm
not going to spend time worrying about
whether somebody likes me or not because
my intentions are correct I intend as a
teacher to see the best in every student
I you know in life could I say I like
this one better than that one you know
maybe but as a teacher no there's no I
like him I don't like him he's in the
room he's come to me for help I intend
to listen I intend to help as best as I
can I intend to help them be as good as
they can be so this intentionality is is
really the way to move forward in life
but you have to know in what direction
you have to have the questions before
that which is what do I want to do you
know and then does it
contribute and then I'm going to intend
to live a life and now my choices is is
does this intention help that along or
does this intention not help that along
I'm going to always choose the path that
helps along my desire to uh to be the
best human being I can be I I you know
if I had another life I would have a
school I would have a school I would
have I would teach people from a very
young age to you know like you know what
is it you want to do and and uh how to
become the best people that they can be
isn't that what it's pretty simple isn't
that what it should be all about I think
that's pretty
simple so many things I want to talk
about here but I I know you think you
said in the book that you loved acting
but you didn't like the the job of
acting and and the the auditions and and
maybe the rejection but you knew you
wanted to help people you felt you did
have a calling as a
teacher what if you have students that
come in and they say you know what my
intention is is pretty pure and clear
and I want to make projects or be part
of projects that you know expose the
greater good or enable people to see
things in a new light but they're
hitting like a roadblock and they don't
know why so their intention seems pretty
pure it's not just to have a certain
amount of followers or whatever that'd
be nice but but they're they're hitting
this roadblock what do you tell them
they're maybe they're not booking roles
maybe the cast that they got together it
fell apart yeah there's no real one
answer to that because there's so many
different ways it could be blocked you
know what you're talking about is I have
an intention I think the intention is
you know a valuable
intention um I've lined certain things
up behind it um and it's not I'm blocked
it's not working so you know in that
case you have to look at holistically at
the actor you know how is their thinking
are they really entertaining a lot of
negative thinking a lot of self judgment
do they have a perfectionism syndrome
there's a lot of different ways to even
though your intention is pure you have
to clear up some bad personal habits uh
of presentation it could be that you
know what I mean but the the basis is to
give them the tools to examine things
very clearly and you know they want help
so you know if you ask things like you
know are you being are you judgment are
you hard on oh yeah I'm really hard on
myself or you know I say are you hard on
others no I'm not I'm not so hard on
others I'm just hard on myself you know
it makes me better you know they think
it makes them better it doesn't make you
any better it's just judgment and by the
way I always tell them hard on self hard
on others hand in hand so you may
recognize one more than the other but
I'm sorry to tell you you know you're
judgment judging yourself you're judging
others and exactly nothing will come up
of that except some false
slightly stomach turning sense of false
security Joselyn how does imagination
cultivate the life of our dreams well to
have a dream to have a life of your
dreams you have to dream and dreaming is
Imagination you use your imagination to
dream you you use your imagination you
know um Einstein talk about imagination
I can't give you a bunch of clever ones
but you should look them up because
Einstein and Imagination unbelievable
another person that I admire and adore
and and and was lucky enough to spend
time with as a child is Buckminster
Fuller Buckminster Fuller talks about
imagination look at Buckminster Fuller's
imagination he went against all gra
Bucky Fuller um designed the geodesic
dome nobody had seen a shape like this
this was an architecture that didn't
exist before but he dared to Dream It's
really that thing of dare to dream when
you dare to dream you engage your
imagination your imagination is the most
powerful thing you have one of the
greatest problems with young people
today is that they're not reading
reading is singularly the greatest
exercise for your imagination if you and
I read the same book we make two
completely different movies our heads
you have to it visualize the movie you
have to imagine the movie from the book
to your head to your imagination to
create a movie you create one I create
another when we watch a movie we are
delivered the pictures and so we pretty
much see the same
movie um when you read you know you have
to make pictures in your head and this
is the problem with with uh today
illiteracy to day is all the pictures
are being delivered and they're being
delivered on television they're being
delivered on your computer they're being
delivered on your cell phone they're
just all these p and advertising it's
just all pictures delivered so we get
lazy and we don't think we have to make
any pictures in our head well if we
can't make pictures in our head if we
can't if we don't read in order to
engage our imagination if we can't have
a dream because our imagination is
flaccid
meaning it has not been
exercised we we become
slaves we become you know pushed around
by anything that comes in our Viewpoint
we can be
led by others with ill intentions I'm
going to go out on a limb a little bit
now and tell you you know I think when
we look back on this time in
history we'll look at it as um corporate
terrorism because it is really this kind
of Corporation this selling of
everything under the sun um that is
stripping away imagination you strip
away imagination you strip away
possibility you strip away intelligence
you you strip away
greatness imagination and greatness same
thing nothing great ever happened on the
planet without first being imagined
there is nothing great about selling
Nikes there is nothing great about
buying every small mom and pop
organization just gobbling up that small
business so you can have oh did you have
another quarter that I haven't gotten
from you let me reach in there and get
that quarter too you know it's just it's
it's astounding and it's you know if we
don't do something about it it's going
to take take a take down the take down
the human race the planet will be fine
CU she doesn't care about time you know
if it takes her another 200,000 years to
grow those old beautiful trees again she
knows what she's doing Bucky Fuller said
you know we should listen to Nature
because she knows exactly what she's
doing and if we just studied a scientist
nature and we took that and rolled the
same principles into our own
sustainability in life we would have no
problems we would have no problems you
know Bucky he was a mathematician he was
a genius he was the Einstein of our time
but people don't know him as well Bucky
Fuller designed he could put the entire
planet on the island of Haiti in
geodesic domes and have every man woman
and child a millionaire he'd proed these
things mathematically it didn't make him
very
popular with uh with corporate world but
you know he he did that he designed two
or three cars but you know they never
they were wonderful cars but no these
people were making money on cars I'm not
going to let you in that that playing
field you know I saw him at the UN he
you know there's a map they finally got
the map of the world correct a flat map
because they couldn't do a map of the
world flat without it getting warped and
this way or that way so of course Bucky
Fuller came along and said oh I know how
to do it and so he did it it's a flat
map and you kind of see it it it goes
like that it
it goes in waves kind of like that and
so to introduce this map they drew the
map on the floor of the UN right giant
version of this map with all the
countries and everything and then they
hired actors and then Bucky did it
mathematically so that you know this you
know in relation to that so the United
States had you know lots of people and
and Africa they could barely stay in the
space in Africa because there were too
many people and then some countries only
had two people and then he did the
resources and he did kind of coins and
he did that mathematically and of course
the United States was rolling piles
rolling and rolling in money and then
there were countries that had like one
chip this is this is our resource and
then you know being actors they started
improvise and so guys in the United
States are like throwing money in other
countries and stuff but anyway this is
all imagination you know this all comes
from his imagination he had one of the
great imaginations of our time
imagination is
greatness do you think most artists
actors writers what have you come from a
family situation where creativity and
Imagination were encouraged or
discouraged and it was an act of
rebellion you have your head in the
clouds all the time get your head out of
that
book you know I'm sure both of those
things are
true I like to think of it as artists
come in with a purpose then they just
forget it so they have to be reminded
but I think both of those things are
true some of them say you know I'm going
to be an artist and some of them say oh
yeah art I should do art but I think
it's a knowingness I think a lot of
times they come in knowing you know I
I'm different and very often you hear
this thing that I had as a child I feel
different I don't belong I can't quite
fit in these people don't seem authentic
to me they're not behaving honestly but
I don't really understand that you know
they they feel a little betwix and
between and so it is the struggle to
alleviate that that uh begins to
stimulate you know the imagination you
know I would go into the garden one of
the greatest gifts my mother gave me was
her Gardens I mean she'd give them to me
but she was a unbelievable Gardener and
she would have these Gardens that that
some of the flowers you'd walk by and
they were ey high they they were like
hello and you would so you know I would
go in those Gardens for four and five
hours and take little things I build
little
Villages how was this imagination
stimulated because I wasn't comfortable
around people so I think a lot of
artists come in that way they come in a
little different and they're not
comfortable around people so they begin
to use their imagination to alleviate
that
discomfort and then what if an artist
becomes a hit and now dance for us again
and now they have to be on in front of
other people yeah and wait a minute my
comfort zone was creating this thing
over here and I'm used to being alone
and what happens
then well that's that's tough that
becomes very difficult I mean they two
ways that that happens you know I I've
worked you know I work as a creative
consultant so I've worked for a bunch of
movie stars and many of them wanted to
be a movie star that that's what they
wanted to do and you know some of them I
think you know they they came in to do
that I mean it just it's so apparent and
then when I would get there the big
secret would be they're not trained they
they go on this desire and this work
ethic and this goal and this intention
to to it's not to be the best it's to be
the most
popular um which often comes from you
know a not enough attention feeling so
I'm going to get this mass of attention
anyway the first thing usually when I
meet them because I was raised with
these painters and dancers and actors
and writers extraordinaire at the Day
dinner table I don't really care who
people are I don't care if you have a
big name
which is makes me popular among those
people because it's very rare and then
after a few minuts it makes months it
makes me unpopular because they're used
to a you know a certain thing that I'm
not interested in anyway the first thing
that happens is they kind of admit that
um I'm not trained I don't know what I'm
doing and I'm always impressed with them
telling me that you know being so honest
but my answer is of course you know what
you're doing look at your career look at
where you've brought yourself you did
this this is no accident and so my first
step is to draw up all the things
they're doing right so we go through all
their films and their process and and
then they can see oh every film I do
have a technique I do do these 10 20
things and then I go go from what you're
doing right into what else is there what
other opportunities are there and then I
would go and do that work for them
because they're very busy you know a
movie star is promoting their last film
working on the film they're going to
shoot next and bringing up the films of
the future trying to find those so they
don't have a whole lot of time so I
would do that work then you have the
person that you're you mentioned which
is the person who is in it for the love
and they just love acting and suddenly
they are a hit overnight and that's very
scary and and very difficult and you
know movie stars love the attention they
they they're very comfortable in that
light uh but not everybody is and not
every actor is and we've you know part
of the problems that we have today is
that you know people are so critical and
they're
[Music]
so you're audience is so expanded
because of social media so where you
would do theater and maybe some people
would be you know in the back you know
in the alley after you performed and
they say can I have your autograph and
you go yeah and that was really nice now
you know you have to have social media
you have to have Instagram you have to
have I don't know Tik Tok and Myck
and it's it's crazy to me but you have
to have those things and that brings
more more more more people this is
really one of the reasons I gave up
acting is that I'm a
shy by Nature you know I want to be in
the woods I don't want you know all
those people looking at me I mean that
was one reason and and the other reason
is I'm too
Alpha I'm too Alpha to take my hat in my
hand and you know I was a trained actor
so I would work really hard in audition
I would bring the audition to the people
with my little hat in my hand and they
would say most of the time it's no I
don't know 19 out of 20 or no and you
know I would have put that time in and
the hair and the makeup and the Wardrobe
and the driving and the thing this was a
six hours on this just to get there 4
hours in rehearsals maybe it's 10 hours
12 hours and you and you're going to no
no I'm no I'm not going to put myself in
that position that's me that's me I I
just to Alpha I'd rather run the show
and be nice to people and you know have
it go the way that I want it to go but
not everybody's that Alpha so you have
to find your way and what's intolerable
to you and what's tolerable to you and
what you can invent for yourself how do
I make it go the way that I want to go
but lastly those those actors who hit it
and then discover I'm not doing well
with all this attention you know that's
a difficult Road and they need support
they need to be heard we all need to be
heard really they need to be heard and
they need to spend real time creating it
the way they want it to go okay now
you're hit now you can have anything you
want in the world
careerwise what does that look like
let's just take some time and breathe
and say what does that look like you
know I introduce people to the concept
of theater because you know theater
actors can w women particularly you know
it expands their lifespan as an artist
to do theater and there's nothing more
fun than doing theater in New York and
in London so you know you kind of open
up the possibilities and
uh really are sensitive to to the
difficulty of that of getting Fame when
you didn't really want it you know you
didn't really ask for it you were just
in it for the work
jelyn you say we are not our emotions
can you
explain certainly feels it I know people
really don't like it when I take away
their emotions but uh yeah no we're not
our emotions we do love them you know I
was just saying if you if you think
about this if you accept the fact that
we Are Spiritual Beings in bodies we are
energetic beings in bodies so we gave
her of this body we have sense you know
we have touch taste sight all a miracle
right all this we can make other babies
new people we can do all these things
and we have this emotion we are here as
energetic beings the
universe has created all itself in all
of these now I don't know how many
people are on the planet but it's way
too
many to experience
itself what better way to experience
anything than emotion we love emotion
but emotion is a product of our
thinking if we're not thinking we're
we're not emotional we get emotional
because we think I lost to me left me I
don't have my man anymore we cry we're
emotionally I didn't get the job they
don't like me we're emotional because
I'm afraid I'm going to die you're not
dead but the bear is coming
and so your body goes I'm afraid I'm
going to die I'm going to die you know
it's kicked up by you know
thoughts so if we're not our thoughts
we're not our emotions we are energetic
beings in bodies here to have an
experience and you know emotion is a
great way to do it emotion also produces
energy you know um I I saw this with
both my parents in in their latter years
when you know they were getting close to
leaving my mother was very dramatic and
she could be dramatic over eggs she
could be dramatic over butter she I mean
big drama it's not right she was a
little affected it's not right I can't
believe they sent me this they know how
long have they known me they've known me
for they I think it's hostile hostile to
send me this kind of but and I would
watch her and it it's like when people
kick that up it it splatters on you and
then you it's very infectious and then
you get mad at them and you go you know
do you have to really seriously does it
have to be like this I mean you've done
this my whole life I don't like it and
now you're in this
emotional
thing so I think I write about it one
day I was in the kitchen my mother was
really carrying on about something she
was also
blind uh I mean not completely but
almost and she was old and she was alone
and cranky and she was carrying on and I
was getting so mad at her cuz you know I
was just home for a trip and trying to
have a good time and really we were just
making eggs and I decided because I had
had so much training with meditation I
decided I'm just going to observe her
which is also what I teach just watch
her without being her daughter without
having this history together you know we
all have our history with our parents
and we're so judgmental and out to
you're wrong and I'm right and you're
worse than I am and I'm better and
whatever it is so I decided I'm just
going to observe her and I just went
into that space and she was carrying on
and and you know I began to see that she
was unhappy and that she was old and
that she was kicking up this emotion
because it gave her energy and it made
her feel more energetic and alive
because otherwise she wanted to feel
like I just I'm almost gone I'm not here
so you know uh we're not our emotions
but we will utilize them in different
ways we'll use them to make other people
feel guilty we'll use them to get
sympathy we'll use them to convince
ourselves of certain things mostly we're
just using them for the experience of
them love you know this neutral space
that I'm talking about kind of is love
but it's not like the love that we think
about because most of the time with love
that we think about we're all wrapped up
with emotion do they love me back as
much as I love them you know love gets
all complicated but this space of no
thinking no emotion this space of
Stillness where higher Consciousness
inspiration and you can connect to your
soul Soul same
space where this other kind of language
can
occur that has no emotion and it has no
thinking so as an actor or a writer
filmmaker don't we need those emotions
though because we're going to at some
point put a project out there that's
going to you know affect people in some
way so we need to really tap into that
well yeah I mean everybody loves emotion
nobody's going to want to give up their
emotion and we're never going to give up
our emotion we love our emotion I think
we've taken advantage of of you know
filmmakers have taken advantage of our
emotions by you know same thing as
corporate you know I want to I'm G to
sell this movie on
fear you know I'm
gonna listen I I did a horror movie I
hate to say this because maybe somebody
will go look it
up I don't like horror movies I was sent
this script when I was young and and uh
my husband I closed the script my
husband came in and I was crying and he
said why are you crying and I said oh
because they're going to ask me to do
this movie they're going to ask me to do
lead in this movie and I'm going to
probably say yes and he goes well you
don't have to and I know but it's
leading the movie and so I made the
movie um and then you know it it's has a
cold following but then the director
made another movie like that and then he
made another movie like that and I think
when you make one genre movie like that
to sort of get yourself known and show I
can do a structure within of you know
this kind of film making you know this
genre of film making and I can put a
structure together in actors and direct
them and here's my camera and you know
show off those things by entering a
genre of picture like that where women
are killed cuz most of them are about
killing women you know I think you get
one I mean this this like a little
opinionated here but I think you get one
you get one okay it got you on the map
you can't go on making movies about
killing women without making a pretty
crappy statement you know so I think
that they're taking advantage of but you
know this is all part of us kind of
rising up and above because once you see
that you go you're not going to you're
not going to manipulate my emotions
because
I'm the only one who can do that I can
have them and I can leave them or I if I
can't leave them I can at least look at
them I can at least separate myself out
and look at them and going boy I'm
crying so hard there is notot coming out
of my nose and running down my lip and
I'm just looking at that just that
separation alone will make you realize I
am not
that that emotion is just part of this
life in a body that I'm
creating and it's kind of cool it's kind
of cool cool it's not you know like no
it's kind kind of cool that's why we
watching the movies we oh it's cool cool
you oh look they're they're they're
emulating that emotion look oh he's
scared she looks really scared oh
screaming she's really screaming you
know it it's anyway did did I answer
that yeah I think so but one good thing
is then we know once we leave the
theater or we turn it off at home that
it's over it's not but but I just
wondered you know how does an artist
separate um um their need for emotion to
put it into their projects versus
dealing with them every day well I think
it's great you brought it up again
because that the the be all and end all
of it is they honor the fact that
they're creating it we're creating it in
life and we're creating it for the film
and we're creating it for the play We're
creating it an actor has to bring that
life out of nothing he creates that
before your very eyes I am not just
going to
pretend that I'm crying I'm going to cry
I'm going to do the things that I would
do if I was crying and I'm going to
stimulate that and then you're going to
enter that and doesn't that show us both
that we're just creating emotions we can
create them we can uncreate them we can
create them we can walk away from them
the actors get in trouble when they
create it and then they go they think
they' P their part they think they look
like better actors if they say I have
trouble getting rid of the emotions of
this part I have take them home I have
to live in the emotions you know you
know you don't have to do that you
create it you know you enter and you
exit freely that's what I tell my
students enter it and exit it
freely then you can go as far in as you
want because you know you're going to
exit what is the power of objective
observation oh this is my favorite thing
we could we could heal the whole planet
just on objective observation it's rare
but it's the most important thing for an
artist I think of all the tools in the
toolkit objective observation I think
actors do it um I was going to say
painters do that uh all the time they're
always looking and when they look and
they observe objectively not with
judgment they don't look at a tree and
say oh tree not nice in the left good on
the right not so good on the left
painters look at things to see what they
haven't seen
before objective observ is the art of
just looking just looking no
judgment so if I say to just look just
spend 10 minutes looking without
judgment can you see that is a rare rare
thing we don't do that and one of the
reasons we don't slow down enough you
have to slow down you have to steal
yourself so it's another way to get into
a meditative state but for an artist
when you look
objectively without
judgment you can discover what you
haven't seen before so most of us look
and see and go I know that I got it
check you know that's it there's no more
learning there's no more
Discovery but if you walk by in New York
I have this tree outside the apartment
that I'm very fond of and that I look at
Daily when I'm in New yor York and I I I
will just spend time looking at the tree
objectively
thoughts Drift Away emotions worry
everything just away I just look at the
tree I look at the spaces between the
leaves I look at the leaves and you know
this is me but I swear you do that and a
breeze will come up and the tree will go
like this and wave at you you'll see you
know a bird make a nest at the top all
of these things are happening around you
you and available to you all of the time
but you have to steal yourself and look
and you have to be
aware of how much judgment you have
because we're trained to it you know
we're all walking around with so much
judgment you know and and social media
isn't helping us I like it I don't like
it the things that people say to people
on social media are just I it's
unfathomable to me
um so those people are a little asleep
and we we have you set an example and
then something else becomes cool we have
to
try we have to try to make Awakening hip
we have to try to make Awakening
Consciousness cool and there you know
there are lots of people waking up at
the same time so we'll we'll find a way
to to make people you know want to do
that more but objective observation is
the artist
greatest tool because it allows them to
see what they think they know and
discover what they didn't see
before and when you work with someone
how can you tell that maybe they haven't
awoken that part yet that that they
don't have it in them at this point well
they well it's because it starts with
the first exercise the environment
exercise where they create a space
because the exercises go in your life
study your life's rhythms study how you
make coffee study how you make breakfast
study how you shave study you know all
these different life the guy who studied
how he got dressed for work uh in his
police job these are all life rhythms
that that we do them over and over and
over again and when we look at those
objectively and discover the behavior we
didn't see before and then duplicate
that behavior so then they come to the
exercise and they're there's not enough
Behavior I can tell that they haven't
been looking for it so then I have them
go back and make a list and bring me the
list what are the behaviors I mean
here's a perfect example my my husband
was
shaving one morning and you know we work
together and and when the studio was
open he was there all the time as well
so he shaving in the morning and he
starts to observe objectively his
shaving exactly how he shaves and the
habits and you know we do all these
little things then he finished shaving
and then he went to put his contact
lenses in he does these things the
exactly the same every morning goes to
put his contact lenses and he puts a
contact lens in and he goes like
this and he said he went and he looked
at a painting that my father did of me
across the room and he looked at it with
his eye that's how he checked to see if
the contact was seated right then he put
the other one in and he looked at the
painting with that eye and he realized
he had been doing this for 12 years 15
and he had never
realized that he did this checking with
the
eyes if you put that behavior into a
movie I'm telling you people will love
it because it's human behavior and
everybody knows it and it was
discovered he looked at what he does
every day what he knows how to do and
discovered something he' never seen
before that's art that's art discovery
is Art you know I I looked for
definition because I'm a teacher of art
I wanted a definition of art that would
Inspire that would light people up I
couldn't find it and I looked in a lot
of dictionaries and you know they talk
about creativity and they talk about all
kinds of things but nothing rang my bell
so I finally asked myself you know what
do I think this is is what is this and
it came very clear to me you know that
art is the expression of that which
you've
discovered if you if there's no
Discovery there's no art it's going to
be just you know a rendition of
something that you've seen before that
you liked you know and you make a little
rendition of that and feels like it's
good but if you discover something now
you have something personal to give even
if it's it's as small as putting your
contacts in and checking and to see if
they're seated right in the picture then
you'd have the shot of the painting
which is pretty dramatic and then you
have the shot of I don't know where you
go from there but it's a beautiful piece
of behavior and the story is told in
Behavior So when you say the word
rendition if we go back to asking an
actor what do you want what do you want
from life oh well I want to be famous I
want to be in this movie I want to do
the next next Blue Jasmine I want and
then you go wait a minute do you really
want to do that or is that a
rendition of what you that that's is is
there something that's more authentic to
you yeah I think that's true I don't
want to be hard on them if they love
blue velvet and they love you know there
all kinds of things add up in them to an
excitement of wanting to be a filmmaker
I want to make films like that but if
you just direct them to this place to
ask questions
if you direct them to these tools like
objective observation keeping your
vibration high with gratitude and you
know what should have so many blessings
anybody making a film has a lot of
blessings you know uh Joy list uh I
think there's several others but
objective observation is one of them you
give them these tools and they will
begin to listen to themselves you know
the entire book my entire purpose of
writing a book
and I don't call it my book because you
know a lot of it just came through um I
call the book but the sole purpose of it
was can I use this technique and these
lessons that I've learned in my life to
help someone listen to The Muse in them
listen to their own soul speaking listen
to that find that place of inspiration
where all of these the same things come
from that one space
which is you know in meditation they
call it the Gap it's a place without
thought and the longer for me the longer
I work with it the more it creates this
kind of a space and it feels like peace
it feels like
relaxation but if you ask questions like
why do I like blue velvet or you know
why do I want you know things will come
in and those things that come in will
move in you and then you'll know oh
that's that's what I want to do that's
that's the Muse that's speaking to me
that's my that's my purpose that's my
goal that's that's authentic that's a
discovery you discover you have an aha
moment you ask yourself and then you go
oh that's that's charged that's gold
that's what you're looking for so the
whole purpose was to lead people to that
space to
question and uh listen for the right
answers and then teach them this one's
loaded go for that one go after that so
it's the Gap the Gap is the
space and when you're in the gap which
is really the present moment you know
when you watch an actor who's you know
all the
time all the time people say you
know you know actors say I want to live
in the moment you this is the whole
movement in acting about being in the
moment is he in the moment he's going to
be in the moment and so people think
being in the moment is
improvisational being in the moment is
not just improvisational that's part of
it to be in the moment improvisationally
okay that's part of it but the moments
are created by you in your imagination
from this story that you want to tell
underneath the story so here's the
script and here's you know your choices
the script is um
the tip of the iceberg and the actor's
work is the whole bottom of the iceberg
so you're going to create a story
underneath that screenplay that brings
that screenplay to life those choices
the more authentic the more aha the more
they're made from that space through
questions that you ask yourself over and
over until you go oh what if it was that
and you put that into the work in a
concrete way
now you're cooking with gas now you're
really creating so there's no worry
about you know he likes this or I have
to worry about is he being authentic is
he not being authentic just lead them to
that space let them practice in that
space let them learn how to observe
objectively let them discover by
observing dis you know let them discover
by observing objectively and then let
them take that Discovery and put it into
the work in a concrete way because it's
not enough for it to be in your head
people think oh I've got this thing I I
have this idea I think it's so great
well if that idea doesn't go into some
form of behavior some form of physical
choice in the
scene it it's all for not it doesn't
exist actors write long biographies I
don't need long biographies I need a
biography that has enough things that
activate certain behavioral choices in
the
seene and have you seen the most aha in
a performance in film or
theater that's a good
question you know what comes to mind the
first thing that comes to mind I can't
believe this comes to mind it was so
long time ago I saw all
Guinness uh in Dylan on
Broadway oh my
God so the end of this play you know
Dylan th about Dylan Thomas he builds
you know he's been told if you have
another drink you're going to die you
cannot drink you're going to die so he
goes into the white hor Horse Tavern and
he builds he orders I don't know 40 shot
glasses and he builds a tower of these
shot glasses he build very carefully
builds them one on top of another on top
of another on top of another and then
the very last moment of the play he
takes the top one off and he shoots the
thing and there's a blackout right I
didn't realize I had watched him build
that Tower with no words just fullon
inner life I don't know 15 minutes 10
minutes that's very brave thing to do in
a play and I had entered it I was he you
know we enter the character we don't
just go into the White
Horse Tavern we enter the character we
experience what he's
experiencing which helps us you know to
realize the genius of
actors if we can enter his experience we
can certainly enter that for our fellow
man if we started entering each other's
experiences a little bit more and caring
a little bit more that that's why I
think acting
reverberates with people so much why we
love artists and we love performance but
I don't think we're aware that that's
why you can't can't be an artist and
worry about what other people think how
is that
possible oh well you can't be a person
worry about what other people think and
you certainly can't be an artist and
worry about what other people think you
know if you track this you know why do
we worry about what other people think I
think you could probably take it back to
your earliest uh Sensation that someone
was judging you and it was very painful
with find it very painful when people
judge us so you know if that happened
when you were very very little and
you're very you know an artists are very
very sensitive so you know it happens
when they're little and they have that
then they're going to worry about what
other people think of them certainly in
puberty your body is changing you know
you don't understand often every once in
a while someone goes through puberty
looking beautiful but for the most of us
you know you're getting braces and
you're not your most beautiful time of
life and you know we worry about what
people think of us and then we go into
high school which is freaking brutal
brutal place it's not natural it's not
where anyone should I mean high school
today is just like craziness but anyway
you go into high school and you're
trying desperately to find a group
somewhere to belong someone to have
lunch with and you worry about what
people think of you um if you try to
create from that impossible that is
impossible there is no creating when
you're worried about what other people
think of you because you will try to
create things that will make them like
you and that's What actors do in
auditions and they don't book the part
because they go on the audition they go
I do this thing that I think that you
want me to do and that way I'll get the
part I'll do what I think you want and
then I'll get the
part none of that can happen the whole
purpose of our is to to to show the path
you know what is the next PATH always
artists are always looking for the new
the new movement where is the New
Direction You Know The Beatles whole new
Direction in music we had a Renaissance
really in the 70s painting and music and
dance and Talia Thorp you know she put
ballet and and musical theater together
and Jazz and came out with something
nobody had ever seen before and Beach
Boys music you know it was like nobody
had ever seen dancers move like that
before you know painters in the 70s
Nobody seen paintings like that before
we don't we don't have that right now we
don't have any new what is the new what
is the forward movement what is the new
way what is the Dow the way and uh part
of that I think is that we're living in
a really judgmental society and artists
put things out and everybody feels like
they're a Critic and and they're mean
and they're really mean so you can't
care about that you you know even more
importantly you can't care about that
because you have to set an example for
those people you have to not judge those
people but say poor people don't know
where that's coming from but it's really
nasty I'm glad I'm not going around
getting my jollies by knocking people
online you know what I mean poor people
let's just set an
example
um the way not to care care about what
other people think of you is to have
confidence that you take counsel from
your own heart so that goes back to how
do I take counsel from my own heart how
do I listen to my higher self how do I
find that same counsil I had at 8 years
old when I said why not they don't see
me I'm sad and they said well we might
have to be enough get over it was a very
matter of fact get over it we might have
to be enough you're blessed you know oh
okay okay I don't think it's solved it
completely but all of these things we
have to practice so we have to we have
to recognize oh I really am caring what
that person thinks of me I think I'll
let that go you know so first we have to
recognize it that takes a little
separation that takes creating a little
space so you can look at you the
personality so you the being can look at
you this personality we work so hard on
these personalities and we think they're
great but trust me you're not your
personality you're something so much
bigger so so much bigger so once you
know that you connect to that and you
can
listen to that you can ask questions you
can listen you can get become in a state
and ask questions and wait for your
heart to beat on the answer so that
higher Consciousness inspiration can
come into to that space you're not going
to care what people think about after
after you experience that and you live
intentionally from that oh this came in
I'm really excited I know what my
purpose is I'm going to move in that
direction here are the steps I can take
are you really condemning me sorry don't
have time I hope your life gets better
you know what I mean you move forward
but but it is that faith that you are on
the right path and that you can continue
on the right path because you have
certain practices that will support that
that will take you to a space of I don't
care what others think of me I don't
worry it's not that you don't care it's
that you don't worry about
it you said something wonderful in the
book too something to the effect of
we're rarely as bad as we think and as
great as we think and that was that's a
really freeing thought yeah it is
because you know actors they think
they're the they get it right they get a
great thing and then they they're like
all charged you know they think I'm cool
I'm great I did that work it's really
good you know I'm great and and they
talk about their talent my talent my
talent I go okay that's good and then
the problem is that that that they dive
from that the minute they they fall from
grace they fall from that to the depths
of oh I God I don't know what I'm doing
and I'm crappy and nobody likes me and
I'll never work again you know my father
was an actor oh my God every time he was
out of a job it was like I'm never going
to work again I mean they
fall into this depressive State and so I
used to tell my ACT I got to tell you
something you're never as great as you
think you are you know and you're like
pumping yourself up and feeling like I'm
hot you know guess what there's
somebody else Who's hotter out
there you know what I mean and you're
never as bad as you think you are so
you're somewhere in the middle middle
stop measuring it because it's a
distraction to measure you know your
time is like a bank account you only
have so much time right you know it's 24
hours in a day and and how many days I
have on the planet but you know your
your time is like a bank account you can
either spend it this way or you can
spend it this way that is your choice
this is very very important this is how
you take control of your life if you are
spending your time worrying about what
people are thinking of you you don't
have that time to do something more
important if you are spending your time
puffing yourself up to I'm the greatest
thing in the world you don't have that
time to go help your friend with an
audition if you you know what I'm saying
so it's all about having enough
awareness to see how am I spending my
time does it contribute to my life does
it contribute to my community it does it
contribute to you
know jelyn would you mind reading a poem
from your new book I know you have many
different chapters and sections in it
but this one is become a master becoming
a master yes I'm going to read you a
little bit before it so it sets up the
poem a bit um you know
uh actors are always asking me how do I
become a master what is a master you
know so this is a bit of an answer to
that forget comparing yourself to any
Master recognize that what you admire in
that person is simply a reflection of
those qualities already existent in
you keep your eye on that ball there in
lies the synchronicity what you already
know you summoned into your life for you
to know again more
profoundly be grateful for that
synchronicity here's what I tell my
students about becoming a master
start keep going you think you're
starting to get the hang of it keep
going
you admire someone else's work and go
into doubt hell I can't do that keep
going you feel like maybe possibly You'
kind of got the hang of it now you don't
keep going you ask someone for an
opinion their response is insultingly
polite keep going you fall into doubt
keep going you fall into depression keep
going you ask someone else's opinion and
their respon is favorable you realize
they have no idea what they're talking
about keep going you feel better and
maybe even a little proud of what you
can do now keep going you chastise
yourself for thinking that keep going
you indulge in some form of self-
sabotage for Comfort keep going
self-loathing Creeps in keep going
depression visits again keep going you
are asked
you ask a professional for their opinion
they respond favorably you think you
know better keep going you wake up sad
keep going loneliness sets in keep going
although you can't possibly imagine why
you become Restless keep going you
receive praise from the one person you
believe matters most it doesn't matter
keep going you just keep going because
there's nothing else you can do
Mastery arrives and you mistake it for a
gust of
wind keep
going what events had led up to you
writing this poem Oh in the oh the
poem well you know actors are seeking
that it's not Mastery they're seeking
they're seeking like where is the end
point where I know that I am glorious or
I've won the Wars or I you know it's
that it is a reach for a satisfaction of
ego you know and they're saying it's a
master you know the master I used to
tell a thing in class about how you know
Seven Samurai is one of my favorite
movies and toiro mufi you know with his
sword he's he's sort of a not a very
good Samurai and he has a sword he makes
a Big Show and he's like slashing
slashing slashing with this thing this W
and uh he's just silly the master comes
along and he has his sword and he goes
and five flies fall to the ground so
Mastery is really less you're so
confident you can do less and have the
same impact you're so confident you can
do less and have a bigger impact and
what is that
less but a Stillness do you see how I'm
going it's less you come from a place of
Stillness so the master is really
working within that Gap the whole time
and if it's acting you know he's he's
working with less but he's more entered
there's a painter I talked to on the
phone yesterday he's is 85 he's a
fantastic painter his name is Julio lorz
if you want to look up his beautiful
work and I was talking on the phone
because we've been exchanging
gifts and I found out his daughter lived
in Angeles so I said are you going to
come to Los Angeles and visit your
daughter cuz I want to see him and he
said no Yi I go why no because no I'm
painting and I said oh well you know
have a place in New York and your son
lives in Brooklyn right yeah do you go
see your son for a visit no
Yi why Julio I am painting you know Yi I
I have too many paintings I can paint
all the paintings that I want to to
paint I'm blew out your microphone I'm
sorry but you know it just knocked me
over that's Mastery he's in it for the
meditation the painting is a meditation
when he's putting paint on a canvas he
is
entering he is entering the canvas he's
not in this world he's not worried he
doesn't worry what people think about
him because he's not coming to visit his
daughter in California if she wants to
visit him you come see me I want to get
on planes I'm old and I'm painting same
thing with his son so Mastery is really
a state it's not something to read I'm
going to I have achieved Mastery no
that's a desire for some super
admiration she's a master he's a master
you know we like to put those labels on
things Mastery is a way of life what is
leaving behind a trail of
breadcrumbs
oh wow you know the cover of the
book um are these hands and I'm
surprised how many people don't know
what those hands are those hands are
from the cave of hands I can't say it in
Spanish I'd love to Rattle it off
quavos something but it's called the
cave of hands and it's in Patagonia it's
in Argentina Patagonia and and those
hands are 65,000 years old they are the
first expression of man I am I was here
I
matter you know uh we had cave paintings
and that those were the stories of the
hunt and the first actors or the guys
who came back from the hunt and told the
story around the campfire and those cave
paintings of animals and such are are
quite old but they are
storytelling these hands are this
impulse and this desire to express
self so they knocked me out
they really knocked me out so a trail of
breadcrumbs you know is from the poem
that opens the book about what is an
artist and they leave behind a trail of
breadcrumbs means they leave behind
hopefully inspired work that when we
look at the it's like a little path this
is inspired work when an artist gives
you inspired work you know just like he
knew it I say oh you know it in your
heart you know when they leave that work
and you see that work you know it you
know that's inspired work that same
inspiration hits you when you see the
Michelangelo you burst into tears when
you see the David by Michelangelo you
burst into tears because it's my my God
that came from man that's
inspired so those are the trail of
breadcrumbs this is the direction we're
going in follow the inspiration to find
out what man is capable of as a
spiritual
being